the marry me concert tour is something
you will not want to miss
in 36 hours superstar kat valdez and
grammy winning bastian will perform
their new song marry me and exchange
files in front of a streaming audience
of 20 million people see you tomorrow
tonight
i'll be the one in the veil charlie this
is once in a lifetime i've got my
daughter tonight good i've got three
tickets for tonight bring her dad you
haven't had any fun since mom left just
say yes
what am i doing here
okay let's go we only have five minutes
what's everybody looking at nothing give
me your phone
cash is husband-to-be bastion caught
cheating with her assistant
[Applause]
hold this i'm told that um 20 million
people are supposed to watch as we take
our vows they say if you want something
different you have to do something
different
why not
yes
[Music]
i'll marry you
you
go go go
do you
some guy
take cat to be a lawfully wedded wife
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
that was crazy kat valdez left the guy
from the concert then also married her
uber driver it's an insane situation i
say we offer five thousand dollars and
let it all blow over or i could stay
married to him
i started something last night and if i
don't finish it i'll look crazy we gotta
get out in front of this kyle
it's three months i don't even know her
we both did this so whether we'd like it
or not we're in this together we have to
embrace the spontaneity of the moment i
don't want to be the punchline
what do i do just stand and smile
this is the most unbelievable thing that
could ever happen in life
right now 237 000 people are like he
looks like he's a math club i am in a
math club
i don't know hanging with you guys today
i don't know it made me feel kind of
normal come with me to the fall
semi-formal
are you asking me to the school dance
well i could leave a note in your locker
call me if you're lonely
hello
are you afraid she'll fall back and love
bastion and help you
i'd be afraid of that too we don't need
to pretend i don't fit
[Music]
this is smart
i think we left smart six weeks ago
i was on my way to you
who do you think you are a man some fan
no i'm not a fan just well i mean i am
now
way
[Music]